[Música]
desde hace 10 años siria ha sido el
terreno de los enfrentamientos de las
potencias extranjeras
turquía a los países del golfo y
occidente han apoyado firmemente a la
oposición
diplomáticamente pero también algunos
financiando y armando a varios grupos
que están lejos de ser moderados con el
paso de los años este apoyo se ha
debilitado sobre todo después de la
intervención militar masiva de moscú a
fines del 2015 este despliegue ruso
permitió al régimen invertir el
equilibrio de fuerzas y recuperar el
control definitivamente sólo ankara pero
en mente opuesta a los kurdos en su
frontera continúa siendo un actor muy
implicado con la oposición lejos de las
cámaras un diplomático francés compara a
bashar assad a una marioneta humana con
dos hilos uno y danny y otro ruso según
él si no hubiera esos dos hilos asad se
derrumbaría y en gran parte es verdad
sin el apoyo encarnado de moscú y
teherán el régimen sirio habría
probablemente caído
pero no es el caso la influencia de esos
dos países es extremadamente importante
para damasco sin embargo después de
tantos esfuerzos financieros
diplomáticos y militares ninguno de
estos dos aliados puede abandonar al
gobierno sirio bashar al-assad logró dar
vuelta a la situación a su favor pues
rusos e iraníes solo coinciden en siria
y el presidente sirio juega con estas
divisiones y a veces ha prometido lo
mismo a rusia e irán el mismo
diplomático de la metáfora de las
marionetas asegura que ahora cuando
vayan al asad siente que el apoyo de
teherán disminuye recurre a moscú que
aprovecha de ganar influencia y
viceversa el mandatario sirio explota
maravillosamente su debilidad
los europeos comparan la situación a
veces con aquella de polonia en la época
de federico segundo y catalina de rusia
dicho de otra forma
rusos e iraníes estarían de acuerdo en
descuartizar a la bestia pero llegará un
momento en que terminarán desgarrándose
entre ellos
bruselas y sobre todo la ex jefa de la
diplomacia
federica mujer y ni quiso jugar la carta
de la zanahoria europa estaría dispuesta
a financiar una parte de la
reconstrucción si damasco acepta una
salida de crisis negociada en el marco
de la onu una propuesta polémica e
ignorada por asad y sus aliados